In the first video
on evolution, I
drew something that
I called an ape.
And then I drew a tail on it.
And what I want to
do in this video
is clarify that that
was absolutely wrong.
Apes have no tails.
And it's actually one of
the main distinguishing
characteristics of apes.
There's obviously other primates
that also have no tails.
But apes definitely
have no tails.
And just to clarify,
there's kind
of two families within apes.
And their common names are the
lesser apes and the great apes.
And the lesser apes are
things like gibbons.
And the great apes are
things like chimpanzees,
and gorillas, and
me, human beings.
So these right here,
these are the great apes.
And clearly, this
great ape right here,
did not have a great
sense of style in 1994.
And really didn't feel the
need to have a haircut.